good evening receiving the Oscar last
year was one of the greatest moments of
my life it is my honor to present the
Academy Award to one of the five gifted
women nominated for Best Actress in a
supporting role and one quick word of
advice the lady that graces this stage
this evening while giving your
acceptance speech take your time no
listen to the music do your thing
and the nominees are Kim Basinger in LA
something Joan Cusack in in and out
Minnie Driver in Good Will Hunting
Julianne Moore and boogeyman's
Gloria Stewart in Titanic
and the Oscar goes to Kim Basinger LA
Confidential
the award for Kim Basinger who was acted
in over 22
oh my god
wait a minute we did only get 30 seconds
and um and to give a thousand thank you
so I just want to thank everybody I've
ever met in my entire life
Curtis Hanson Curtis Hanson Curtis
Hanson the cast and crew from the movie
I could not have done this without them
Annette wolf my great friend Georgia my
sister Ashley my husband Alec my baby
girl Ireland um if anyone has a has a
dream out there just know that I'm
living proof that they do come true
thank you so much to the Academy I'm so
grateful for this and daddy this is for
you
you